we're hoping you can give us a brief
profile of how you found distribution
for each of your films from outside
sales weathergirl 6-month rule and now
with cut to the chase
sure outside sales was we didn't know
what the hell we were doing that's a
very important thing about my first
movie we you know I I was doing well
acting wise and like this was that the
movie that I sold my house to finance I
you know had done this cartoon for
Disney 4 where I do the voice of Peter
Pan and I made a good amount of money
and I bought a house and then I sold the
house to finance my first movie and we
had it and we traveled all over the film
festival circuit and spent all this
money and then came out the other side
and was like alright I'm broke I don't
have distribution for the movie and you
know what do I do
so that one was crazy it took about a
year of just like talking to everybody
and finally we landed with this company
and got a DVD deal which again this was
when the the system wasn't working very
well so it was like we got a DVD deal no
money up front but they threw us a big
release party and that was pretty much
it but the movie was out that was an
important thing
weather girl was a way better experience
wait weather girl got into the Slamdance
Film Festival
we had some cool actors we had Mark
Harmon and Kaitlin Olson and Trish oh
Kelly who was on the new adventures of
old Christine and they all came out to
Park City with us and that helped
promote the movie and we got a
distribution deal right there and then
we sold to lifetime which was we're
really where the money came in so that
paid back all of our investors and then
we had this huge international deal
where they never paid us so we had to
sue this company in order to get them to
settle for one fifth of what they owed
us again the system just didn't work it
was the kind of thing where people the
distributor's not all of them but a lot
of them would just refuse to pay until
you sued them because they knew you
didn't have any money so if you sued
them and got that far then they would
settle for like one fifth of what they
owe you which is a you know a lot of
them
politically this kind of business is
being talked about a lot right now and
in my experience it happens all the time
of like the little guy screaming yelling
about where's the money that you owe me
and then then saying no no no all right
here I'll pay you one-fifth and you'll
be happy to have it luckily that's
happening less now with distributors but
that was weather girl so weather girl we
made all of our money back but before we
got into profit we had this problem with
our international distributor six-month
rule we premiered at the Austin Film
Festival film buff came to us film buff
is cynics kind of little brother in the
indie film world and they put us out
itunes VOD and everything like that it
was a great experience we're still out
there with film buffs 6-month rule check
it out and cut to the chase finish the
film and we've just been traveling Film
Festival wise and like having
conversations and we met with 108 media
and they they seemed down with the movie
and we certainly speak the same language
and they're bringing us out March 7th so
I'm excited
you